.
WE ARE ONE STEP CLOSER TO THE
END OF AN ERA IN ISRAELI
POLITICS.
THE COUNTRY'S LONGEST SERVING
PRIME MINISTER, BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU, APPEARS TO BE ON HIS
WAY OUT.
CENTRIST POLITICIAN HAS PULLED
TOGETHER A DIVERSE GROUP OF
RIVALS FOR A NEW COALITION
GOVERNMENT.
RIGHT WING RELIGIOUS
NATIONALISTS WOULD SERVE AS
PRIME MINISTER FOR THE NEXT 2
YEARS.
WORD OF THE AGREEMENT WHICH
STILL NEEDS APPROVAL BROUGHT
CELEBRATIONS IN TEL AVIV.
>> TONIGHT, WE ARE CELEBRATING.
IT IS UPON US TO ENCOURAGE THE
GOVERNMENT OF CHANGE.
AND NOW THEY'VE ANNOUNCED
THERE'S A NEW GOVERNMENT.
>> ELECTIONS THAT WERE ANALYSTS,
AND NOW WE ARE VOCAL FOR A NEW
STATE GOVERNMENT.
>> LET'S GO LIVE NOW TO
JERUSALEM, AND DURING MOST
ELITE GOT CAN.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, ELLIOTT.
WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THIS?
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT WITH THIS
HISTORIC BUT FRAGILE NATIONAL
UNITY GOVERNMENT?
VERY FRAGILE KIND OF RAINBOW
COALITION AND WAITING, ISN'T IT?
IT'S MIND-BOGGLING ITS BREATH,
RANGING FROM A FAR-LEFT THROUGH
THE CENTER EVEN TO THE RIGHT OF
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU.
AS YOU SAY FOR THE FIRST TIME
EVER INCORPORATING A PARTY
REPRESENTING ARAB CITIZENS OF
ISRAEL.
WE SAW PEOPLE CELEBRATING ON
THE SEEDS OF TEL AVIV.
GURLEY MANY OTHERS IN ISRAEL
WHO WILL NOT BE CELEBRATING
THIS MORNING.
INDEED, WE'VE HEARD FROM
NETANYAHU WRITING THIS AS A
LEFT WING GOVERNMENT TO
SPOKESMAN FOR NETANYAHU'S PARTY,
WHO TWEETED EARLIER TODAY THIS
IS --
TO THE EFFECT OF THE LEFT IS
CELEBRATING, BUT THIS IS A VERY
SAD DAY FOR THE STATE OF ISRAEL,
ADDING BENNETT SAW, THE LEADER
OF THE RIGHT-WING NEW HOPE,
PARTY AND THE NUMBER 2 SHOULD
BE ASHAMED.
CERTAINLY, IT'S HISTORIC,
WHATEVER YOUR POLITICAL
PERSUASIONS ARE.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY ALL OVER THE
NEWSPAPERS.
NOW IT'S TRADITIONAL FOR THE
PERSON WITH THE MANDATE WHEN
THEY SPEAK TO THE PRESIDENT OF
ISRAEL TO SAY IT'S IN MY HANDS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THE NEWSPAPERS
HAVE BEEN PLAYING ON A TERMS OF
HEADLINES.
THIS IS ONE OF THE LEADING PAID
FOR NEWSPAPERS IN ISRAEL.
THE HEADLINE THERE IS IN HIS
HANDS WITH A PICTURE OF THE
LEADER OF THE ISLAMIST PARTY
CITING THAT COALITION
AGREEMENT.
SIMILAR HEADLINE IN ANOTHER
LEADING PAID FOR NEWSPAPER IN
ISRAEL, IT'S IN THEIR HANDS
WITH A PICTURE AND THOSE WHO
HAS A DUDE HAVE A GOOD PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP.
BUT THEY WERE IN GOVERNMENTS
TOGETHER, A LOT OF COURSE BY
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU IN THE
PAST.
THEY GET ON WHILE AT A PERSONAL
LEVEL.
THIS IS ISRAEL TODAY.
THIS WAS --
YOU COULD ACTUALLY SEE THE NEWS
OF THIS COALITION ALMOST
RELEGATED TO A SMALLER STORY.
THE MAIN FOCUS HERE BEING THE
NEW PRESIDENT OF ISRAEL, BUT
THE HEADLINE IN THIS NEWSPAPER
WHICH IS PRONE IN YAHOO SAYING
HE SUCCEEDS.
NETANYAHU HASN'T GIVEN UP.
THIS NEWSPAPER REFERRED TO AS A
PORTMAN TO OF THE NICKNAME OF
PREMISED OR NETANYAHU AND THE
WORD NEWSPAPER IN ISRAEL.
PERHAPS OMINOUS WORDS THERE,
BUT ALSO PERHAPS A WARNING
NETANYAHU REALLY HASN'T GIVEN
UP, AND OF COURSE HE WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN HIS POWER TO TRY
TO DERAIL THIS COALITION,
EITHER BEFORE IT COMES INTO
BEING, OR AFTER.
THE OTHER MAIN ASPECT OF THIS,
AND REAL HISTORICAL
SIGNIFICANCE IS THAT FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER, A PARTY
REPRESENTING ISRAEL'S ARAB
CITIZENS IS GOING TO BE IN A
COALITION GOVERNMENT.
THE LEADER OF THE PARTY
SPEAKING MOMENTS AFTER HE
SIGNED THAT AGREEMENT.
>> I JUST SIGNED AN AGREEMENT
SO WE CAN FOR GOVERNMENT AFTER
REACHING A CRITICAL MASS OF
AGREEMENT ON ISSUES THAT WILL
SERVE THE INTERESTS OF ARAB
SOCIETY, AND PROVIDE SOLUTIONS
TO URGENT PROBLEMS WE FACE IN
VARIOUS FIELDS.
>> PROVIDING MORE RESOURCES FOR
ISRAEL'S ARAB CITIZENS, PERHAPS
TRYING TO TACKLE A HIGH CRIME
RATES AND MURDER RATES IN THEIR
CITIES.
WOULD BE TOO CONTROVERSIAL FOR
THE COALITION GOVERNMENT,
PERHAPS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WILL GET OUT OF JOINING THIS
COALITION.
BY AND LARGE, THOUGH, AS I SAY,
THIS KALEIDOSCOPE OF A
COALITION WILL SEEK TO AVOID
ISSUES THAT DIVIDE THEM.
DON'T EXPECT ANY PROGRESS ON
PALESTINIANS OR ON SETTLEMENTS,
THINGS LIKE THAT.
INSTEAD, THE FOCUS WILL BE ON
PASSING A STATE BUDGET.
WE DIDN'T HAVE ONE PASSED IN
2020 AND ISRAEL.
THEY HAVE TO PASS THE BUDGET
FOR 2021 AND 2022.
OUR FOCUS ON THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY, POST CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC, AND AS A SIDE NOTE, A
LOT OF RESTRICTIONS RELATING TO
CORONAVIRUS WERE LIFTED EARLIER
THIS WEEK.
AND THEY WILL FOCUS ON TRYING
TO HEAL SOME OF THE DIVISIONS
THAT HAVE EMERGED IN ISRAELI
SOCIETY, OR PERHAPS BEEN THROWN
EVEN WIDER IN ISRAELI SOCIETY
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF PRIME
MINISTER BENJAMIN NETANYAHU.
FINALLY, TO SAY, HE IS DOWN.
CLOSER THAN HE'S EVER BEEN TO
LEAVING OFFICE IN THE PAST 12
YEARS.
HE'S NOT OUT JUST YET.
AND UNTIL IT'S OVER, IT'S NOT
OVER.
ROSEMARY?
>> EXACTLY.
A LOT TO SEE, WE'LL SEE WOULD
HE MAY DO NEXT.
ELLIOTT GOT GONNA BRING US THE
LATEST LIVE FROM JERUSALEM.
APPRECIATE IT.
WITH ME NOW IS PROFESSOR OF
POLITICAL SCIENCE AT THE HEBREW
UNIVERSITY OF JERUSALEM.
THANK YOU SIR, FOR JOINING US.
>> GOOD MORNING, ROSEMARY!
>> GOOD TO SEE YOU.
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT BENJAMIN
GIVEN YAHOO WILL FIND A WAY TO
DERAIL THIS HISTORIC NEW DEAL
BEFORE IT'S EVEN APPROVED AND
WHAT'S POSSIBLE OPTIONS REMAIN
FOR HIM?
>> I'M NOT TRYING TO ESCAPE THE
ANSWER, BUT IT'S 50/50.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN A
LONG TIME SOMEBODY ELSE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO TRY AND GET
TOGETHER A GOVERNMENT.
LET'S REMEMBER THIS MAJORITY
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO BE 61
OUT OF 120 SEATS IN THE ISRAELI
PARLIAMENT.
THAT'S A RAZOR THIN MAJORITY.
IT'S MADE UP OF 8 DIFFERENT
PARTIES.
IN OTHER WORDS, FOR BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU TO TRY AND PICK AWAY
AT IT AND BREAK IT DOWN EVEN
BEFORE HE'S SWORN IN AND ABOUT
11 OR 12 DAYS, IT'S LIKE LOW
HANGING FRUIT.
IT'S QUITE EASY FOR HIM TO DO
IT, ESPECIALLY SINCE THE PARTY
GOES FROM EXTREME RIGHT TO LEFT,
IT'S EASY TO FIND AN ISSUE THAT
WILL RIP THEM APART.
>> LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THAT.
IT IS A TRULY POLITICALLY
DIVERSE COALITION, WHICH
INCLUDES FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
ARAB ISRAELI PARTY ALONG WITH
THE EXTREME RIGHT AS YOU POINT
OUT AT THE EXTREME LEFT.
THE ONLY THING THEY TRULY AGREE
UPON RIGHT NOW IS GETTING RID
OF NETANYAHU.
BUT THEN WHAT?
HOW FRAGILE FOR THIS COALITION
OF 8 PARTIES PROVED TO BE?
AND WHAT WOULD THEY BE ABLE TO
AGREE UPON APART FROM A BUDGET
GOING FORWARD?
>> YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD.
WOULD IT BRINGS ALL OF THEM
TOGETHER, PARTIES THAT ARE MORE
TO THE RIGHT TO THE NETANYAHU,
AND PARTIES THAT ARE MORE TO
THE LEFT OF NETANYAHU.
IS THERE DISLIKE FOR NETANYAHU.
WHAT'S ONCE HE IS OUT OF OFFICE,
THE GLUE WILL BEGIN TO FRAY,
AND THE QUESTION IS, HOW LONG
WILL THEY SURVIVE?
IF NETANYAHU WOULD RESIGN, THEY
WOULD PROBABLY COLLAPSE A LOT
SOONER, BUT HE HAS ALREADY
STATED HE IS NOT GOING
ANYWHERE.
HE STAYED AS LEADER OF THE
OPPOSITION, AND HE IS GOING TO
CHALLENGE THEM EVERY DAY, WHICH
MEANS HE WILL STILL PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF BLUE TO KEEP THEM
TOGETHER.
NOW, WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS WIDE
COALITION GOVERNMENT, ANYTHING
THAT HAPPENS ON THE SECURITY
FRONT, SUCH AS ANOTHER BARRAGE
OF MISSILES FROM GAZA COULD RIP
THEM APART SO EASILY BECAUSE
THERE ARE THOSE WHO WANT TO
RESPOND FORCEFULLY, AND THOSE,
AS YOU SAID, THE FIRST TIME
EVER, THAT AN ARAB PARTY IS
SITTING IN GOVERNMENT IN ISRAEL
THAT WILL HAVE A MUCH MORE
CONCILIATORY APPROACH.
BEYOND HITTING NETANYAHU AND
EVENING BUDGET, WHICH WE
HAVEN'T HAD IN OVER 2 YEARS,
HOW CAN THIS COALITION STAY
TOGETHER?
THAT'S THE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION.
>> INDEED.
AND FOR HOWEVER LONG A NEW
COALITION DOES LAST, NETANYAHU
WILL, OF COURSE, BE ON THE
SIDELINES, AS YOU POINT OUT, AS
LEADER OF THE OPPOSITION,
WATCHING FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET BACK INTO POWER.
RIGHT NOW, HOW SIGNIFICANT IS
IT THAT AFTER 12 YEARS IN
OFFICE, HE IS ISOLATED AND
APPARENTLY HAS VERY FEW ALLIES?
>> LET'S LOOK AT IT
HISTORICALLY.
NETANYAHU WAS FIRST ELECTED IN
96.
THAT WAS 25 YEARS AGO.
HE LOST QUICKLY, AFTER 2 AND A
HALF YEARS AND WAS KICKED OUT
AND THEN HIS PARTY, THEY CAME
BACK BUT UNDER SOMEONE ELSE.
NETANYAHU HAS SHOWN US THAT
EVEN IN OPPOSITION, AND IN
THOSE, DAYS PARTY HAD ONLY 12
SEATS, NOW THEY HAVE 30, IT CAN
FIGHT IN THE TRENCHES AND
PARLIAMENT.
HE CAN CHALLENGED SITTING
GOVERNMENT.
IT CAN MAKE THEIR DAY-TO-DAY
TRYING TO HANDLE THE GOVERNING
OF THIS COUNTRY A NIGHTMARE.
ANOTHER WORDS, AS ELLIOTT, SAID
IT'S NOT OVER UNTIL IT'S OVER.
AND YOU CAN NEVER COUNT
NETANYAHU OUT.
THE ONE THING WE NEED TO ALSO
FOCUS ON IS THAT HE HAS A COURT
CASE, AND IN THAT COURT CASE,
WHATEVER HAPPENS THERE WILL
HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT ON
POLITICS.
IF WE SEE THAT HE IS ABOUT TO
BE GUILTY, THEN HE IS FINISHED.
BUT IF WE SEE THE COURT CASE
BEGAN TO UNRAVEL AND HE MIGHT
BE INNOCENT?
HE WILL COME BACK FULL FORCE.
>> THAT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME
TIME, THOUGH, ISN'T IT?
I MEAN, AS WE, KNOW IT ALL
MOVES VERY SLOWLY AND ISRAEL
WHEN IT COMES TO CORRUPTION
TRIALS LIKE THIS.
OR ANY TRIAL.
HOW SOON DO YOU THINK WE WOULD
KNOW HOW VULNERABLE HE IS?
>> THIS WILL TAKE AT LEAST A
YEAR OR 2.
THEN AGAIN, WE GO BACK TO THE
MAIN QUESTION OF CAN THIS NEW
WIDE COALITION MULTI PARTY
COALITION SURVIVE UNTIL WE HAVE
A FINAL DECISION IN THE COURTS?
AS LONG AS NETANYAHU IS AROUND,
THEY JUST MIGHT STICK TOGETHER.
AS SOON AS NETANYAHU DISAPPEARS,
AND IT COULD BE FOR POLITICAL
OR FOR LEGAL REASONS, THERE IS
NOTHING TO KEEP THESE PEOPLE
TOGETHER.
IT'S EVEN WORSE IF NETANYAHU
WAS TO LEAVE HIS OWN PARTY,
THEY COULD TURN AROUND AND FORM
AN ALTERNATIVE GOVERNMENT
TOMORROW.
THE PARTIES THAT ARE NOT
SITTING WITH NETANYAHU ARE
DOING THIS ON A PERSONAL ISSUE.
NOT ON A POLITICAL ISSUE.
THOSE MORE TO THE RIGHT AND THE
RIGHT-WING DID WHEN THE
ELECTIONS IN ISRAEL.
THOSE TO THE RIGHT WOULD BE
HAPPY TO FORM A GOVERNMENT WITH
THE PARTY AND JETTISON THE
EXTREME LEFT ELEMENTS, BUT NO